here's how you answer this question who
is god when somebody says so david who
is god what do you say
well there are a lot of different
answers you can certainly waffle your
head off about a question like that you
can talk about a platinus-like
access to ever more refined layers of
reality a god followed by successive
successive superior gods that sort of
thing um
i think we're pretty limited we're
limited to a particular tradition which
is the judeo-christian tradition that's
where the resonance exists and we
we understand that tradition best i i
know there are hindu tradition has a
completely different conception of god
the buddhist tradition has a different
concept of god but i can't talk to those
because all i know from those traditions
i know as a matter of scholarship
not intimacy
the judeo-christian god is outside
time and space outside the physical
universe it's not one of those things we
encounter within the universe
it has certain attributes certain powers
which we assign to it i mean this is
theology it's not a matter of a physical
science we're not discovering this
and
there are two there are two or at least
three additional doctrines associated
with the question that you just asked
one is the the very old idea that um
within human beings there's a kind of
image of god
that is there is a
asynchronous appreciation god for human
beings human beings for god which is
manifested
in art
by the assumption that a human being
somehow
reflects the divine the second
assumption is that the surest path to
intimacy
with the deity lies with it
and that's certainly what the buddhists
say as well that is the
what is within gives you the
the surest most accessible way to reach
the divinity
and the third is a series of
pronouncements about human nature
that are part of western theology
for example the christian doctrine of
fallen human nature
which suggests to get back to your
question that when we talk about god i'm
talking about
people in our position
we talk about god we we're talking about
uh
a theoretical entity and it's just
theoretical because we have no hands-on
experience it's beyond experimental
science
who has an intense personal interest in
moral judgment
and that's an aspect which i think is
severely neglected
when we talk about god we're not talking
about
someone who fulfills a certain
role
in explaining how the universe came
about well he created the whole thing
okay we know that we know that that's a
traditional assumption
but a less traditional assumption
especially in the 21st century it's not
only a creating god it's not only a god
with enormous powers embarrassingly
large powers it's not only an infinite
god but it is a guy and this is the
crucial point it's a god who has a
peculiar interest in our moral nature
and who is prepared for example to judge
us
that's part of the judeo-christian
tradition
the judging aspect and it has been
the foundational stone for virtually
every system of judeo-christian morality
since at least the fifth century bc
very much neglected
because the question is wide open when
you take that foundational stone away
you just yank it away
and you eliminate
the idea of the universal system of
judgment
judging human beings for their acts
during their life
um what's the result
what happens to society when you take
that foundational stone away this has
been
a question that i think is has been
pertinent since at least
1830 when the great movement of secular
liberation from christian doctrine
began to accelerate and spread to every
corner of
every corner of europe in the united
states we're talking about a 200 year
old process secularism is not just the
last 10 years it's a long complicated
tradition
and we are living in a secular society
it's absolutely obvious we're not living
in a society where people are consumed
by the thought of judgment or that
they're proposing in any way to put
inhibitions or restraints on their
desires
or to conform in any way to
whatever the code of conduct may have
been enforced in the 18th and 17th and
16th century
who are in fact proposing to make it up
as they go along
which i'm afraid we're all doing
um but when you remove that judgment you
were making a point about what happens
when you remove that judgment what
happens well
it's it's like asking what happens in a
physical system you withdraw the energy
from it i mean the physical system can
look just the way it it did before
but there's nothing doing any work
anymore let's just say it's a piston
with no external source of of energy
driving the piston
well
i i i cannot say look
it's perfectly obvious what happens but
i can say if you want to know what
happens there is a correlation between
the rise of secularism and the nature of
society look around
look around
are people restraining their behavior
are they inhibited
a traditional series of codicils being
enforced throughout the answer seems to
be no secularism seems to allow a great
many things that previously were
forbidden is that just come down to
accountability is judgment
accountability is i mean
something that pat always talks about is
accountability like who's holding the
politicians accountable well you know
the voters but
that's a whole other question but
judgment at the end of the day comes
down to accountability are you going to
be accountable for your actions good or
bad
is that essentially the that's a good
question i think it's very similar to
the question i was raising i mean hobbs
said the fear of death is the source of
law the fear of violent death is the
source of conscience
it's a source of conscience because
violent death
you meet death without any preparation
any theological preparations and you're
going to be judged instantaneously
that's a very pregnant remark by by
harps but i think
that accountability is another way of
saying look we're now living in a
society where the essential force behind
judgment
the thing that made it live
that's been progressively withdrawn
there's no point in denying it seems to
me no point in saying well we've
we've recreated
a moral universe in every way comparable
to the the moral universe that we have
denied or derided if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you